got some news to bring you now from avon
and somerset police this is regarding
the 15 year old girl maddie thomas who
went missing in bristol
on the 26th of april um
suspicion that she had been kidnapped
well avid and somerset police say that
she has now been found uh
they have found her at an address in
bristol uh she'd been missing from a
home in the south mead area of the city
as i said since the 26th of april uh
avon and somerset police saying three
men inside the address have been
arrested on suspicion of child abduction
both maddie's foster parents and family
have been informed and detective
inspector laura miller said we are
delighted to confirm maddie has been
found three men are in custody and will
soon be questioned by officers we're
grateful for all the support the public
gave us in our search for maddie and
would like to reassure them that she is
now being provided with all the care and
support she needs we appreciate there is
significant interest in this case and
i'd ask people not to speculate and to
think about the impact it may have on
maddie and her loved ones so that is
maddie thomas the 15 year old girl who
has been missing in bristol since the
26th of april uh found today at an
address in the city